So this is probably the nightstand female is
haunted subscribe to us
subscribe
No my sister is the last one delivered
together they found 78 together
they all are positive in sequence now
They said I already put it first
Believe me if I try it is now
destiny
Vote this will pass us by
That's why I fell under 50 kilos.
It's hard to explain
.
The last or just be
oh oh oh since he has been
talking about the period before his illness and everyone knows
that those who know it are positive people, that is, the
positive positive gift was ordinary positive,
it can't turn slightly negative Tell him,
come on, a red one like that to himself
, he's like he says I
can't get through.
For example, in this
patient, it has been 441 days.
It
is not a situation reported with positivity or in the literature until today, but again, I say that when we cannot
make a culture in any way,
let me tell you for sure whether this virus is alive or not, at a rate of up to ninety-nine percent,
the probability of this virus being alive and therefore
contagious is now yours.
To remove
it, I will either remove it or
bury it correctly Toprak there is no other choice
so
subscribe